great
i hope this controls will will
okay good evening so for for the crowd
uh on the internet who will be watching
who'll be watching the
the streaming or the youtube version of
this
i will briefly introduce myself and and
the topic of tonight's uh presentation
my name is alexander molluck and the
topic for for tonight is the causal
discovery in python so this talk is
has a practical aspect
but it also has a theoretical aspect and
this is because
the topic of causality in general
requires certain assumptions
and i'm deeply convinced that
understanding certain assumptions and
certain theoretical concepts
will make it easier for you
um to to work smoothly with those
ideas and and tools that we'll discuss
today
okay without further ado let's go and
let's start with an agenda
so we'll start with a quick introduction
then we'll talk about causal inference
and causal discovery so these are two
slightly different
um
sub areas of causal research of causal
of causal learning then we'll talk about
causal graphs
then we'll talk about methods of causal
discovery so we are focusing on causal
discovery in particular today
but as we have
a little bit more time and you will be
if you if you will be interested in
hearing more about causal inference as
well
i think we can also talk about it
and finally we'll do a little bit of
practical
of practical a couple of practical
examples
in python using certain libraries so
i'll share with you
like very basic workflow for causal
discovery and also hopefully we'll be
able to see in action
uh how
certain concepts that we'll discuss
before
can be can be leveraged and how
they can help in interpreting the
results of a
of a causal discovery
process and finally we'll have
q and a but as we agreed before please
feel free to just interrupt and mute
yourself and ask questions as we as we
go because i believe that's something
that might give you just more value from
the stock
and you can prepare your qr code reader
if you have one because we'll have a
couple of
interactive materials over along the way
so
so this might be helpful for you
um
kitty i must i have to ask you one
question do you see this control panel
here or not
control panel for
for zoom
yes
okay i'm trying to i will try to remove
it somehow but i don't know how
so i will leave it because i don't know
how how to remove this is it affecting
your presentation is it okay or
uh no for me it's it's fine i was just
thinking that it might cover something
along the way but
let's check it maybe it will be fine
okay
um
[Music]
okay great so let's so let's um go
let's do the
then
so here are two main um resources for
today uh the repository is on your
left and on your right it's it's a
direct link to the notebook that is in
within this repository inside this
repository that
that the left qr code links you to and
also for those of you who do not have
um
a qr code reader you can use this uh you
can use this address so you could have
com like thundermore dogs and workshops
and then you should find it uh spy data
hamburg and we'll leave the screen on
for a couple of seconds
so you can copy the address
okay
so um let me introduce myself like uh in
in like three or four sentence sentences
uh i'm a machine learning engineer and
researcher at ireland's iron scales and
machine learning researcher tencel cell
my main main
areas of expertise or focus on natural
language processing you know
probabilistic modeling and causal
inference or causality in a broader
sense i also write a thing that is
called sunday ai papers which is a
weekly micro blog on linkedin
so if you're interested in
the like bleeding edge
like recent most recent papers now in in
the areas of nlp or probabilistic
machine learning the causal machine
learning and so on feel free to
to
connect on linkedin and i'm trying to
write sunday papers weekly but lately it
was a little bit challenging so it was
bi-weekly
but uh this is something between weekly
and bi-weekly anyway
i'm also interested in complex systems
uh psychology and neuroscience and
psychology and resilience are part of my
academic background
and i really enjoy traveling with my
wife
running i love vegan food and i really
like languages languages
natural and programming
okay so let's talk about causality
what is causality so now now i will ask
a question um
that's my question to you so what are
intuitions what is causality in general
so we are not looking for like a precise
definition here it's more like about
your understanding it's always very
interesting to hear
um
how people have different ideas
sometimes about this
so what is causality what are your ideas
about causality
so um
there are
uh two
main categories of causality in my mind
one is the
constructor sequence of fundamental
physics
and then another is
the
correlation between
uh
proceeding in succeeding events
they say there are two you have two
ideas or two concepts of causality in
your head and the first one is
about physics and about physical world
so how one thing
like what causes the other thing is is
that correct
well both
the the concept in general is one of
succession of
events
um
in which
uh one event precedes another
the
how you
characterize the events
will
determine the
meaning of that connection
but uh
you know at the
i have two intuitions one is that there
are fundamental events
um in the physical world which are
uh have a uh
uh
well
so there's a
one config one state follows another
state predictably
um
characteristics of the state uh prior
state determined characteristics of the
subsequent state
uh those may be stochastic
but um
that's
the fundamental
you know
underlying substrate the material
substrate but
when we talk about um observations
at the macro scale
that's a bit different because
we don't have a
complete description
of
the
microstate reductionistic description we
only have
correlations
between sets of properties in a prior
state and sets of properties in a
subsequent state
great
i think there are great intuitions uh
anthony thank you so much for sharing
this
i think you touched upon a couple of
very interesting um
and crucial things
and
well what you said about physics and
reductionistic uh reductionistic
explanations of
of large-scale phenomena is something
that i think is even much more deeper
than we will be able to
to touch today
but nevertheless i think many of those
intuitions that that you mentioned
will come back in two days in today's
talk
so thank you so much for for sharing
do we have any any more voices any more
intuitions
um
maybe in a perspective or history of
science that there were once a
belief that if you know
the state and the movement of every
particular universe you can predict the
future like this old-school determinism
in a way
and
this this has proven
wrong so but this was a working
hypothesis of
modern
science uh a really
a really long time and
there are new concepts and
new
i come from the social science political
science and we know
agent and system interactions where you
have a practice and part of the practice
is a reflexive
part so
everything is shaped
by circumstances but you can shape the
circumstances so uh the oh the whole
concept of causality isn't gone but
um is much more narrow in a way and
moved
away from this classical determinism in
a way so
thank you that's uh that's a very
interesting perspective so as i
understand the
a perspective that you that you gave us
is is more of a complex systems
perspective where
uh where we don't have a deterministic
system where high level
emergent properties uh might have
let's say a chaotic relationship
with uh with a lower level
uh simpler
simpler processes
that's that's very interesting um
and this and this is something that i
think those intuitions that we got from
anthony and from dennis
they give us like a very broad
uh very broad perspective on on what
causality can be that it can be many
different things
so what we we'll try to do today we'll
try to find a framework that is
actionable
that in a sense
is abstracting away a lot of those
uh
very important and very very deep
ideas that we can
that we can meet when we think deeper
about causality
okay so let's let's see what wikipedia
says now after everything you said this
seems i think this this might seem very
simplistic
but this is the definition from from
wikipedia
uh a definition of causality as
understood in physics
and it says causality is the
relationship between causes and effects
is it a good definition
well i don't know
it seems that it's potentially a
circular definition because we try to
explain causality using causes
but whatever this is what it is but this
is just one example of many many
definitions of causality that are out
there
um and in another talk i have a couple
of examples of those here i only have
this one
but as i said before we'll try to find a
framework that lets us abstract a lot of
very difficult
philosophically difficult
things and
and give us a tool that is very
actionable that we will be able to build
upon or build with
using this tool
this tool this definition comes from
judy apple
who you could think of as a godfather of
causality so he devoted most of his
career
to research on causality first in
bayesian networks
then
actually building a causal framework
with with his students as well and his
definition is very very
simple so it says a is a cause of me
b
listens to a
and this listens to
well sounds well metaphorically of
course but um what it means is that if
we change so if we make an intervention
on on on a
then b will also change
and as anthem anthony mentioned before
it will change in a predictable way
given certain
circumstances
circumstances so
so this is the definition that that we
will
basically
use
implicitly today so most of the stuff
that we will work with
will somehow
uh will somehow
depend on this definition but well you
could agree that you could argue that
some
methods might be less
[Music]
it might be less
requiring of this definition than others
anyway do you have any comments or
questions at this stage
okay so i'll take it as i know
okay so now i have another question to
you why model causality so
we have machine learning
we have statistical learning we have
deep learning and all this like
this uh
fancy uh very complex
models today like transformer models
models that can
mold like very very very complex
functions
in in in high dimensions
and
this has been
this
this models has been proven
actually very effective as well right so
today we are able to
solve
many problems
that even 10 years ago
it would be hard to imagine that we
could solve those problems using
computers in in a relatively
relatively easy and efficient way
so why should we model causality why
should we even bother if machine
learning is so good do you have any
intuitions from this
i would say to reduce
future uncertainty
to reduce future uncertainty so so you
would see a difference between
um
the way that we can try reducing future
uncertainty using regular machine
learning versus causal models
again the questions
so um
you said that
um reduction of future uncertainty is
something that
could motivate us to use causal models
so my question to you is if you see and
if yes
what is the difference between
regular machine learning as complex as
you wish and causal models in this
regard
in the context of
future uncertainty that he mentioned
[Music]
um
i really really don't know i'm really
into the
the answers provided by this talk so
yeah
but i think to
one have to reduce future uncertainty to
to act um to to increase the rationality
of one's action so this would be the
purpose
in the first place so
great
okay great
to design interventions perhaps
design interventions
what would that mean to design
interventions
to exploit the causal discovered causal
structure in order to
uh effect some control outcome
uh
and
you know a simple example like treating
a disease with a specific molecule
uh excuse me we also have a raised hand
from detect
yes hello magic yes
so
i would also say that
to them to like uh to
debug
wrong
causality so for example there were
recent examples of
uh chest
chest x x-rays of the patients with
covet 19
that the machine learning mechanism
algorithm was very good at detecting
whether
the
uh the patient will
will have some severe covet okay it will
be a cervical case but what it appeared
that
the
machine learning
model just learned to differ from the
stand up x-ray chest from the laying
down x-ray chest and if someone had
laying down xhs they already had
some problems so it was
so i would say that if we discover what
how what's the causality discovered by
the machine learning model we can then
discover how useful this model is
so okay great thank you for sharing
thank you anthony and thank you thank
you matthew um great intuition so
matcha you mentioned something that we
call in causality a confounder a
confounder is a variable that is
affecting
both our predictor and the the variable
that we are trying to predict
okay and and
and this is uh something that can
have a very very profound effect
on the way
we
compute our results we interpret and we
interpret our results
we also have another we also have
another answer here in the chat from
tara
and this answer says for
interpretability
so this i i feel that this goes maybe a
little bit into the direction of what
you mentioned anthony
you said about interventions uh so this
is slightly different but
i feel there is this there is a common
uh let's say common route to those two
and to answers actually to all the free
answers that we got
okay great so
we also have
we also have one input from tara she
said it would be for
interpretability
interpretability yeah so this is what i
what i just mentioned from tara yeah
exactly
thank you
uh great so
so so now let's go and let's see another
angle
uh why we
would be interested why we could be
interested in modeling um causality
so let's start with with another
question how to increase the number of
non-commercial space launches per year
and i will give you an answer
to increase the number that we to do
this we should increase the number of ph
these phds i'm sorry in sociology in the
u.s
do you think it's a good answer
okay oh we have another answer here from
james
free humanity from correlation based
thinking
that's a very that's a very nice uh
answer thank you and somebody unmuted uh
themselves to say something i guess so
um please feel free
yeah alexander that's great
oh sorry
um i guess i will go ahead um i just
regarding your question is whether it's
clear the answer of about increasing the
number of kids this i guess you found
probably the very root of the problem
in your assumptions that you made maybe
you can depict them as a graph but
and then you
introduce that as an answer um but i
guess this is my answer because i'm also
coming from the field of machine
learning probably it's not very clear
but that's what i understood it's not
very clear how you derived this
conclusion
uh but i'm pretty sure that you derived
that based on some assumptions and
associations that you made along the way
between different variables
yes so
so actually this uh this comes from the
real world data and this this answer is
uh 100 100 data driven
and as you can see those two variables
are very very highly correlated
i will show you also uh another
view on this data which is a scatter
plot you can see that's correlation is
really really strong
and now
if we use a regular machine learning
algorithm
like in this case this is a linear
regression line fitted here as you can
see
this answer would be a very very good
answer in many
in terms of many metrics and many
popular metrics that we use
uh for
that we use for
assessing the quality of our models
and of course this idea when we we think
about it as as humans and we talk about
you know uh
phd phds in sociology as a cause for
space launches
um we might think hey actually how could
that work right and we can we can start
asking
uh questions about the causal mechanism
but classical machine learning
algorithms
cannot do this because
what they do they actually focus on on
on correlation and that's the
and that's actually the hard part
um
but let's think how could we address
this so
i will start with causal inference
although the main topic of our today's
talk is causal discovery i'll start with
causal inference because in a sense
uh i think it's a better start
so what is causal inference well causal
inference is a process of estimating
causal effects from observational data
so anthony mentioned before
that we can try using a causality for
designing interventions
but what we're actually trying to do
in in in this
at least in this view that that i'm
presenting now we are trying
to to understand to read the
interventions from the data so it would
be
the opposite direction in a sense
and now
to do this we need
a causal structure so as we
said
a minute ago
traditional machine learning or
statistical learning algorithms cannot
uh find out causal relationships because
they do not have
a causal model of the world at least the
most of the models that we are using
today now
so so we need some causal structure to
provide these algorithms with
and we can think of it as i think a
story to the data
so causal structure
is something like in our example right
we say hey is it possible that
doctorates in sociology
uh because
uh or influenced the
influence the number of uh
non-commercial space launches like
causal influence
in the same year you know if we look at
this and see that it happens the same
year it's not like we have more
sociologists in the
in the society and maybe in some way
uh it inspires other people or inspires
the policy uh change that's you know
that um
influences the number of of space
launches it happens in the same year so
we would be very i guess so we would be
most people be very suspicious about
this and would say
you know maybe there's something else it
actually influences both things right
maybe it's like fina financial situation
in certain
institutions or something right
would like we would probably go and try
to find something
and and something is a story it's an
of narrative that we find plausible
given
causal models of the reality that we
that we've learned
along during the course of our own lives
so those models also need these types of
narratives these types of stories
and
and this is all about causal inference
so if we have data and we have a story
about data
so about this you can think about the
story also as a
um some description of the data
generating process
then those models
are able
under certain assumptions
to
find and estimate
true causal effects
in your data
that will not be
susceptible to
to
[Music]
mis-estimates
that would appear there if we only rely
on correlations
and i see that giant wrote in the chat
that correlation does not imply
causation exactly so
so this is exactly
this is exactly an example of this
now let's talk about causal discovery
we can go back to this data and story uh
later if you if you want
so puzzle discovery is a process of
estimating causal structure from
observational data
so now first we say okay to perform
causal inference we need something extra
not only our data set we also need the
story or this some information about
data generating process and now we are
saying we are saying that there's
another process called causal discovery
that leads us to discover the story
or read the story from the data
so it's like reading the story from the
an observational name
um we can view this also from a slightly
different perspective
go going back to this machine starting
from regular machine learning
we could say that
excuse me
we could say that uh in machine learning
regular machine learning we have data
and then we have a model and this model
is trying to
trying to leverage
um
relationships between variables in our
datasets but there's also a certain data
generating process that generates this
data
but our machine learning model
is is completely
naive when it comes to this data
generating process so
if there are confounders
in the data generating process
our machine learning model will not know
about it so it will not know
that there is a confounder in our
dataset
and also a little
little little detour here
that i think uh some of you who are
machine learning practitioners might
find interesting
is that
when we are training machine learning
models
we often think about regularization
techniques as something that might
improve our model's quality and that's
certainly
true in in many
in many various meanings
because we can reduce overfitting and so
on and so on but from causal point of
view
uh regularization might be actually very
detrimental so if we have a highly
regularized tree-based method like
like maybe
random forest or maybe gradient boosting
and
and we train these models and and they
will push even let's take even let's
take a regression with regularization
you will notice that variables
that are
less relevant will their coefficients
will be pushed towards zero
and this makes the model
in a sense
in many scenarios more robust to
overfitting
but at the same time what we are doing
we might actually
favor
variables that are confounders
and
and mute the true predictors because
those confounders
might have relationships to a couple of
predictors and in this sense they will
have
a higher predictive power
than any of those predictors
individually
but this predictive power
might be at the same time
very dangerous in a sense
that it does not that the model
uh
leveraging those confounding variables
will be even further from the true
causal
relationship to true causal structure
between our variables so in case of any
concept drift that might be very very
detrimental so this is something that
might be counterintuitive that
regularization might have this dark side
let's say
but but this is what it is
so when i understood this for the first
time i was i was very surprised and i
thought wow that's
really interesting
in a sense it's something that
can also be very actionable
if you care about uh causal
relationships when modeling your
problems
okay so
let's go back to the graph
we said that in machine learning our
model is naive in terms of data
generating process and it only relies on
the data
now in causal inference we are taking
some information about the data
generating process and we also
send it to the model
we provide our model with with some
information about this and in case of
discovery
we are again getting this structure but
we are trying to estimate it from the
data itself okay
so
this leads us to a situation where we
actually have another estimating
building block here so it's like it's
another
type of a model that is trying
um
that is trying
that we are trying to fit to the data
but we are trying to fit it to the data
using pretty different logic than in
case of our regular machine learning
model
and now as you and also as you see all
those models here
uh
this is all this is all very very
similar
if we don't look here right
and this is not an accident because when
we are estimating causal effects
we actually can use pretty much the same
models
not maybe not always and we are not
always using them but in many cases we
can just use the same
same set of models that we are using for
regular machine learning the only
modification is that we need to provide
them with this causal
with this causal
structure the information about causal
structure
and causal discovery so this little
block is the main focus of our talk
talk today
okay so now it's time to talk about
causal graphs but before we go there i
will ask you if we have any question
regarding what we said so far
does it make sense what we said so far
do you feel like
it clicks for you
or is there anything that you feel we
should
we should talk about uh a little bit
more
it's pretty clear to me
so as there are no other voices let's
continue to call refs
to talk about to introduce those causal
graphs we'll talk about an example and
this example will be a fire alarm system
i've seen in the chat that somebody
mentioned the
book of why
at some point and
if i remember correctly this example is
actually
taken from from this book or maybe there
was like a very similar example there
okay a couple of important assumptions
uh our fire fire alarm system
reacts to smoke
so it does not react to fire itself it
does not react to temperature it just
reacts to small particles in the
air and we have only three elements in
this world in our example
it's fire which is binary either there
is or no
there is a fire or there's no fire
or
the second the second entity in our
world is smoke which is also binary yes
null and there's alarm also binary yes
no
okay
so now
assuming that all those assumptions that
we discussed before are true
we can draw a causal graph of our
alarm system
and it would look like this so we have
some fire
fire causes smoke and smoke causes alar
of course in the real world
there might be
there might be smoke coming from from
outside the the window
and this is all uh stochastic and it's
not perfect but for the sake of this
example let's just think about this very
simple world when we have fire smoke
okay
so this is um i guess this is pretty
intuitive
and doesn't require too much
too much talking so now let's do
something let's make it a little bit
more abstract so let's replace fire and
smoke and alarm
with a b and c but before we do it i
will i will go back to here and tell you
one thing
so one important thing here is that
when we have smoke
but we don't have fire the alarm will
ring as well
okay
if it's a stochastic system it will ring
with some probability if it's uh
if it's a deterministic system it will
just ring
so this is important because it shows us
that in this type of structure
when we control
or intervene
on the variable in the middle then
the state of the variable here in the
beginning
is not important which means in
statistical terms
but also in gram in graphical terms
that
given
smoke alarm is independent of
fire
and this will be true both in
deterministic and stochastic scenarios
okay so now let's get more abstract
so now we have a b and c
and this structure is called it is it
has its own name it's called chain
so in the chain this important feature
of of a chain
is what we discussed before that given b
c and a are independent
but this is not the only
possible structure
and we are only limiting ourselves to
three element structures
another possible structure for free
elements will be something that we would
call a fork
so as you can see there's a slight
difference because
now this arrow is not going from a to b
but rather from b to
a
which means in causal terms if if we
agree that this graph represents some
kind of a color model but b is a common
cause of a and c
an important feature of the fork
is the same
as a feature of a chain that given b
a and c are independent
okay but when we don't control for b
they will be dependent
which is also true for a
chain
so now what we are talking about we are
we are talking about
graph independence structure
which is closely related to another term
another concept of d separation
okay now let's go to the third example
this is the third structure it's and
it's called a collider
and collider is very very special
because collider
because collider property
is precisely the reverse of the
properties or if there's the important
properties of
a fork and a chain that we discussed
before
so a and c
will be independent
when we are not controlling for b but
when we control for b
they will become dependent
okay this might be counter intuitive
but this is true and now we'll see
that it's it's not only a graphical
property but it's also a statistical
property
so i run a simple experiment
and i want to share with you now
so what we have here
we have those three variables a b
and c and c is the dependent variable so
we are trying to predict c
with both a and b here in all three
cases and we are running a simple linear
regression
over a simple
random data set
so now let's look at the coefficients
okay so we have a chain
so chain is a structure that we started
with
where a causes b and b causes c
and
as you can see
we are controlling for b
and b is a
significant predictor of c
but a is not
but if we would remove b from here a
would become significant
same is true for for the fork
you can see that we are controlling for
b and a is not
a significant predictor of c but if we
would remove b
it would become significant
and you can run this experiment yourself
i will show you a qr code for this
notebook in a second
but
the situation for collider is different
as you can see we are controlling for b
and a is a significant predictor of c
so this is very interesting and this
gives us
and this gives us
a very powerful tool
to learn
about dependence and independence
between variables
in
in real world data
right so for every three variables
we can
order them in different ways and
direct and redirect edges between them
and learn something about the
independence
between those variables
and this is something very very
important
very very powerful and very very basic
for both causal inference and causal
discovery
do you have any questions regarding this
section
okay i'll take it as i know
so now
let's talk about causal discovery
methods so we talked about three basic
uh three basic structures
graph structures a chain a
collider
and a four
and now we'll talk about three different
groups of methods for causal discovery
and some of those methods will actually
use
those independent structures that we
discussed
a minute ago
okay so there are three families of
color discovery methods it's not a
complete um
it's not a complete
typology let's say
because you can also have mixed methods
and so on and so on but
for the sake of this presentation
and
general
and general understanding of this topic
i think it's very convenient to think
about it this way
so first we have constraint based
methods
and constrained
means that we are actually using those
um graph independences
in dependencies um
that we discussed before
this is uh also based on on the set of
assumptions that we'll talk about a
little bit um a little bit more in a
second
then we have score based methods so
score based methods they are trying to
generate
causal graphs
and
compare them
in terms of their feed to to the data
and finally we have functional methods
so functional methods are trying
to find
functions
are trying to i'm sorry
so functional methods are assuming that
there are functional relationships
between
variables
and
and they are trying to leverage
asymmetries between
between distributions like noise
distributions and so on
one very important thing is
that when we talk about causal structure
or the story that we also
the story of the narrative that we
provide the model the causal model a
causal model with
the story is most of the time
represented as some
as some kind of a graph
of course those graphs might have much
more elements than this a b and c
but
but those graphs uh if they have at
least three elements
can be analyzed using those
independencies that we talked about
before
okay so constraint based methods as we
said they are leveraging the graph
independent structure
they are also they are based on an
assumption that there is a mapping
between graph independence and
statistical independence in the data
okay and and this
assumption is called faithfulness
one example of
constraint based methods so-called pc
algorithm this is a classic
classic algorithm classic
causal discovery algorithm
and we'll see
an example of this algorithm today and
also we will discuss how it works so you
will see how we can
how we can analyze a graph using those d
separations uh using the separation or
like graphical independencies
and how we can find out the causal
structure from the data itself retrieve
code structure
the second
family of methods are score based
methods as we said those methods are
trying to build graphs and
compare them
and compare them
in terms of the feed to the data
now you can generate many many graphs
but in problems with many variables this
is can be hard
so
not really practical
so
we have
we are using
some types of heuristics some of them
pretty smart to
do a search over
the graph
space in a way that is feasible and
insufficient
and one of the
examples of score based methods is
greedy equivalent search
so as you can see this greedy
if you have an intuition that greedy
might
have to do something with the fact that
this problem is empty hard this is a
very good intuition
and finally we have those functional
methods
so there are leveraging symmetries and
irregularities in variables and noise
distributions
they assume that
the causal relationships might be
expressed as functions
so here we have our
our chil our child ex our parents so
parents in this sense in in this
terminology are variables that are
causing y so x is causing y and we also
have some noise
and we have many different types of
moles with additive noise non-additive
non-additive noise
and so on and so on
and one example of functional methods is
uh lingam algorith algorithm which
stands for
linear non-gaussian
linear non-conscious non-gaussian model
okay and as we mentioned before
um
[Music]
there are also
other methods
some of them are hybrids
trying to combine
trying to combine
score based methods
and
and independence-based methods we have
methods uh leveraging much reinforcement
learning in many different
in many different forms
and finally we have end-to-end
causal discovery and inference methods
where we are trying to
in in an end-to-end process we are
trying to
discover the causal structure
and
estimate the causal effects
and some of those methods
are based
or maybe even most of those methods are
based on
generated models which means that they
are
they are actually building a generative
model
that can also
that can not only um
not only estimate causal effects but it
can also you can also
impute missing data in your files so
this is this might be pretty convenient
but this is a very
you know some of those methods are
really super fresh so it's like some of
them
were published like maybe two months ago
so this is uh an ongoing
ongoing research process
okay so now it's time to go and do some
some practice
do you have any questions or comments on
the previous session
before we jump into
coding
um have you mentioned it
would you say that a random forest model
that works with gin so to
what reduces the most entropy is
in
is
a part of one of those families or
would you don't uh sort this
random forest in in this context
so random forest might be used for uh
for causal
inference i'm not aware of any
of any
of any paper or any research using
causal using random forest for causal
discovery
but it can certainly be used for causal
inference but then it it needs to be
uh
used in this in a certain specific way
so
random four is just taken like
you know out of the box won't give you
reliable causal estimates
of course in certain simple problems it
will because in certain simple problems
uh correlation will be causation
actually
uh but in general
in general in general in general i'm
sorry uh it won't be true
does it answer your question yeah
absolutely super yes
great very interesting
thank you thank you that was a very good
question any more questions
okay
so let's jump to the to the notebook
now i think uh we already have links in
the chat thanks to mache
thank you much hey and also like we have
a call i been i see that's great that's
very very nice of you
okay so let's do it
oh i see
it is open in the other
in another window
so
okay
great
so for today's session we will use a
couple of packages and let me introduce
you you know to these packages
uh the most important one is called g
castle
it's called g castle but we import it as
castle
it comes from a huawei research team
which is called noaa's arc
it's a very
interesting package so it's not super
popular
but in my opinion
it's the most complete one so they have
implementations of like really cool
really modern methods also classical
methods
one method that we mentioned which is
called ges which is a score based method
is not implemented in this package and
that's why we are implementing we are
importing it separately
but i talked to
to the
um development team of g castle and they
are actually working on their
implementation of ges so it will be
included in castle zoom
um otherwise then gcastle we are using
networks
mainly for
working with graphs mainly for
visualization purposes
we are using numpy for something
warnings because gcastle might
send you a lot of warnings at this stage
in this in this
in the current version
um and what else and maple sleep for
visualizing stuff and that's pretty much
everything
everything in both okay so let's import
this
we'll turn off the
we'll turn off all the warnings
uh but of course you should not do this
in
in the in the real life projects
uh if you want to install the
environment you can do it with the
provided yum file
it's in the repository
okay this is some helper function that
will
build a graph for us
and now let's talk about pc algorithms
so as you might remember pc algorithm is
a is an example of constraint based
methods
and
it is fully based
on on independent structures in the data
so we will take this example which comes
from from a great uh review paper uh by
uh by kirmura and colleagues
um and we'll implement it there but
first before we start implementing let's
understand what is going on here so
let's read the description first pc
algorithm starts with a fully connected
graph so it takes all your variables
that you have in your data set and
builds a fully connected graph
of those variables and then it performs
a series of steps to remove edges okay
so you might if you
if you think about it
uh and if you remember in the the
description that we had
the discussion that we had regarding
those independencies
you might have an idea well where are we
going now
and and of course it will happen based
on this graph independent structure and
finally
it tries to orient as many edges as
possible
and
it is not by accident
the formulation is not by accident here
it tries to orient them
as many as possible
which means
that which means that it won't be able
sometimes in certain cases it won't be
able to
uh direct all edges
right
so in certain cases we will get
something that is called the markov
equivalence class markov equivalence
class
are graphs that have the same sets of
independencies
so sometimes if you remember
chain and fork they will have different
directions of
of edges of one of the edges
but actually independent structures
are identical in both
which means that pc algorithm as
the only thing it can do it can leverage
those independencies independent
structures
it won't be able to decide
regarding one or two edges which
direction there should be
they should be
they should be looking at okay
so
so let's say that this is our graph so
we have x and y causing z and z causing
w
we said that pc algorithm is starting
with a fully connected graph so this
little figure b is
showing a fully directed graph between
all those variables and then it removes
edges based on the independent structure
so it's it starts with something very
simple it looks a pairs of variables and
sees if there if there are pairs of
variables that are
there are variables that are pairwise
independent right and it tries to find
those
pairwise independence
independent variables and remove edges
between them
then after this it is trying to orient
the edges between variables that are
that are left and as you can see this
structure here x y and z this is a
collider
so the model
just took x and y and controlled for z
and noticed
that
the variables became dependent when z
was controlled four
so it knew how to orient those edges now
between y w and z
you don't have a collider we already
know that y is is directing here
so
the edge from z to that we have we need
to have a an edge from z to w because
otherwise if we had
an edge from w to z that would cause it
would that would create a collider here
and we know from the independent
structure
that there is no
no collider here
oh thank you dennis
hopefully you'll be able to see the
recording
also katie if if it's too long just let
me know okay i'm i'm ready to speed up
for anybody
sure yes
sorry again i was not able to hear it no
no problem uh yeah
okay
okay so now let's try to implement it so
we'll take a thousand samples for to
from um from a random normal
from
normal distribution from standard normal
distribution for x and the 1000 for y
so these are our variables that they
have no parents right
and then we'll create z by adding simply
adding x and y and adding some gaussian
noise
and then we'll compute w
as point seven of z
plus plus again some gaussian
okay then we'll create a little data
frame out of this
do a sanity check
now let's do some codal discovery how we
do it well we just take this algorithm
we just take this class pc we initialize
an object of this class
we first
imported this from castle algorithms
and then we just say pc dot learn so we
use learn method and we pass our data
set with variables
what we get
when we fit the the model it gives us a
causal matrix
so this is how it looks
is it correct i don't know let's
visualize this
and we have okay x is causing v i think
this was correct right we had x and y
causing z
and y is causing z as well and z is
causing w
which is also correct
well so that's great
now this is a very simple
algorithm but as you can see it's it's
pretty powerful
but is it always powerful well let's see
so let's do some more
causal discovery
we'll now generate much more complex
data set actually a set of data sets
but before we go there uh let's ask if
let's see if we have any questions
or comments maybe you have a comment you
want to share with us that will be also
that's also very welcome
okay is it clear so far uh is there
anything that you feel we should
devote more attention
to i think uh everybody is following
quite well
hopefully
great
okay thank you constantina
okay so then let's build some some more
complex data sets we will use to
generate them
we will will actually generate random
data sets right to generate them we use
something that is called a scale free
model
so if you if you're interested in graphs
you probably heard about this
um if not this is a certain
distribution
over graph
over graph
distribution of edges over nodes
that is trying to mimic certain
real-world
graphs
real-world structures that could be
represented as grassroots
scale-free
networks is something um is something
that
was uh described by by barabasi and
albert
it was a very famous uh
it was a very famous uh
prayer of uh
scientists both
originally from hungary
and
albert is considered to be actually a
godfather of network science or
something that we extensively use today
in networking in security in many
different in many other areas
great so we will generate a scale-free
network
now this network will only give us like
an empty let's say skeleton of a graph
without any variables and relationships
between them and then we will fill in
the scale-free graph
using three different types of
of relationships and distributions so
first we'll we'll build a linear and
gaussian
data set then linear and exponential and
then nonlinear non-linear quadratic data
set
this loop will
contract this for us as you can see this
is very fast we only have 2000
we have only 10 nodes 15 edges and well
and 2 000
examples or observations
you can see our data sets we store them
in a dictionary
thank you
okay
okay so so let's uh
look at those visualizations just to
understand
what we have there
so we have the the gaussian is gaussian
lux gaussian
exponential looks exponential
and you can see that the non-linear data
set is not linear right those scatter
plots are a little bit
a little bit extended in the in the
horizontal direction but you should be
able to see this uh still more or less
so
that this one is is non-linear and also
the distribution as you can see is
uh is very skewed
okay so we can now visualize the graph
that we constructed so this is our graph
based on
based on the scale free
scale free architecture
this is the same graph but represented
as a matrix so this is something that
we'll
extensively use during the presentation
and now we'll do something we'll compare
a couple of methods so we'll take the pc
algorithm that we've seen
in the beginning of the notebook and it
performed very very well for
uh for the simple graph that we started
with then we'll use ges algorithm which
is a score based algorithm
and
then we'll use a lingam which is a
a functional algorithm linear
non-gaussian additive model lingan
stands for this and we will use a
certain flavor of this algorithm
based on ica ica is independent
component analysis
and finally we'll use golem so golem is
a little bit more advanced algorithm
it's it's
it's trying to find a graph using
certain certain methods i i don't want
to go too deep into this but it you can
just think about golem as an algorithm
that is
in a way
capable of of modeling more complex
relationships in your in your data
and now what we're going to do
is that we will run this i actually run
this before because it takes a little
bit of time so we can look at the
examples
it will take a couple of minutes so i
don't want to rerun this i don't want to
lose
[Music]
it
waste your time
[Music]
okay uh so the first data set was linear
and gaussian so this is uh something
that pc algorithm usually works well
works good with
and as you can see it worked pretty well
but it did not work as perfect as in the
in the first example that we had so you
can see that we have some edges here
that that are not in the original data
we have some edges that are missing
um
so
the on the left it's the estimated graph
and on the right it's the true it's a
true graph
that's our true graph
so
you can see a couple of statistics here
number of undirected edges is one so if
you remember we said that this algorithm
might provide us
with a with something that is called a
markov equivalence class so a graph that
is not fully directed might be partially
directed
you can also see that precision and f1
score in terms of finding the edges is
not perfect and false discovery rate is
point is 0.2
so false discovery rate in
in in pc algorithm might mean that we
actually found
have found uh
some that we actually have some
undirected edges in our graph because
from the matrix point of view an
undirected edge will be represented as
two edges from
x to y and from y to x or from like node
zero to
i don't know what it is three and from
node three to
zero we don't have it
uh but there are edges like this here
okay now ges algorithm so this is a
score based algorithm and we said that
it's it's building a series of graphs
and trying to
and trying to fit them to the data and
compare them on some kind of
fit metric
in terms of some kind of a fit metric
like
bic or aic or
or other metrics and as you can see ges
is not doing a very good job here
so it also has one undirected edge this
algorithm also might i might find edges
that are undirected
but f1 score is much more much lower
false discovery rate is much higher than
in case of of bc finally we have lingam
which stands again i will say this again
because it's important to interpret the
results it's linear non-gaussian
additive model
and because this data is linear and
gaussian we actually would not expect
this model to perform very well and this
sentence is true it didn't perform like
tragically bad but it's not a very good
performance
um
neither
and finally we have gollum and as you
can see golem modeled the data perfectly
so
you can see that recall precision and f1
score are all one false discovery rate
is zero and number of undirected edges
is also
zero okay the second data set is not
only is linear but exponential
so i
i didn't tell you but pc algorithm
usually works the best on on simple
gaussian linear data sets and you can
see this here as well so you can see
that we have like two undirected edges
already comparing to one
comparing to one in the
in case of the
um
the first data set which was linear in
gaussian
and f1 score
is actually slightly better but
precision is worse
and recoil is better
ges is not performing very well again
lingam though is performing perfectly
so
because this data set is non-gaussian
it's exponential
lingam is doing
well very good job here
and finally golem and you can see the
golem again is doing a very good job
here with a perfect fit
similarly to what we got from
and finally we have the most challenging
data set non-linear quadratic
as you can see pc is not performing very
well it's actually performing pretty
pretty poor
uh f1 score of 0.38 so this is pretty
poor
um
ges is performing a little bit better
but just a little bit oh no actually
it's
actually it's it's performing the same
that's interesting um
yeah but i it seems that it's actually
performing exactly the same in terms of
those metrics that we're using
lingam
well
it's performing very poorly as well uh
it's even worse than the other ones
um because the small it works well for
gaussian stuff so we don't have gaussian
stuff here
it's known gaussian and finally we have
a golem
and the most complex model in a sense
and it performs well
it performs not very good but much
better
or relatively better than the other ones
now one thing to
mention about column here is that we
only run it for twenty thousand twenty
five thousand iterations and we could
have done this for for longer
and there's a chance that this model
would
would
would give us uh much better results so
you can run it for 1 000
you know 100 000 iterations even more
and it can get better sometimes the the
likelihood is not dropping here
maybe h is just moving a little bit
uh but it's worth trying so it's worth
to experiment
but actually we haven't run this um this
example now live because of golem
um
because of the computational cost that
golan
that golem
i'm sorry um
[Music]
the computational cost that um this
model is generating so it it would take
the most of those computations would be
taken by this algorithm it's more
complex it works better on certain data
sets
but it's also it also takes much longer
to
to train
okay great so this is the end of the
notebook
and i'm just wondering if my
presentation is still in the
presentation mode after this attack yeah
but it seems it is
so this is time for questions
um
and
also this is time if you don't have
questions
or maybe you won't don't want to ask
your questions first you can also scan
this qr code and this will direct you to
a quick survey and i'll be very very
grateful if you could fill this survey
because it will help me prepare better
presentations uh in the future uh it is
short it should not take you more than
one minute
to fill
you can also use this link if you don't
have your qr
qr code i will try to copy it
oh sorry wait a second
all right copy
it would be great to have the link
yes yes
let me let me try oh yeah i think i can
do it like this
cool
um
can i copy this link
okay i'll do it like i will do it
differently
okay
and then let me let me put it in the
chat
and it should work
okay great so
let's see if we have some
questions
or maybe we have some comments
comments are also welcome
uh did you find this this topic
interesting um
from like your research point of view or
maybe your
work point of view do you think this is
something that could be
useful for you
um alexander yeah i i found it very
interesting um it's not
for the time being directly involved
like linked with the projects that i'm
occupied with but
for my prior projects in neuroscience
where causality is a big issue uh i
liked a lot your conceptual introduction
so
that was really good to hear that you
yeah think things through apart from
coding and doing the software
engineering job so
i really enjoyed it so thank you
although for now as i said you know it
doesn't um
yeah it doesn't clip with something
specific but i'm pretty sure it will
it will come because i study graphs
and
i do drug discovery now so i'm pretty
sure at some point we will occupy
ourselves with causality so yeah
very interesting rock discovery is a
fascinating topic
i agree yeah it's it's it's really nice
and it's
relatively speaking quite uh quite new
as a field
i mean the intersection with networks
and machine learning so
yeah
yeah
great
thank you so much thank you for sharing
and thank you for your very kind words
hi alexander i have a question maybe
just a
question to start probably discussion
more likely than write your own answer
so
i was wondering um
about the discussion between correlation
and causality
so we know that machine learning
especially the majority of the models
must be learning they deal with
finding associations between variables
so i was wondering what is the
importance of course it is important to
learn causal discovery into causal
inference but
what are the cases that actually causal
discovery adds value or
maybe we can discuss about that where
causality can actually improve
the performance is this a matter of
improving the performance of the model
or actually building
more a model that better fits
the world or the context that we are
working on
um
i don't know and probably another
question is did you any of the models
that you describe use a fitness metric
that is different from um a likelihood
or uh
but i guess this is the second question
great questions thank you um so i will
start with the first one um
so you ask if if causal discovery can
bring value in in fact right that's your
that's your first question and where it
can bring balance yeah over the over the
traditional machine learning model which
deals with correlations
so there are um i think there are many
um
there are many areas uh where it can
bring value
the most uh
well the first thing that comes to my
mind but this is probably because of my
experiences is marketing
so
there's a thing in causal um in causal
in causality there's a sub area that is
called um
that is related to modeling
um
something that we call
conditional
treatment effects
so
we were focusing on causal discovery
today more than causal inference but i
will start the answering your question
from causal inference point of point of
view
so you might imagine a situation where
um
you are running a marketing campaign
and now you're measuring
the outcomes of your campaign
and you're training some machine
learning model
to predict
when
and
in to what extent you should advertise
your let's say product
now it might be the case
and it in reality it is it is often the
case that
among your customers
there are people who are
who are reacting differently to your
campaigns so maybe you have email
campaigns
and maybe you have some people that
actually read your emails
and then this influences their behavior
so it makes them more likely to buy your
products
and this is a dream scenario for me
right because you are investing some
money
and now
from those people
with some probability of course
or some expected value
you will get some returns
but now there are also people who will
open emails or maybe not even open them
they will just put them
put them in spam
now you also might have people
that will just buy your products anyway
and you
but maybe even more importantly you
might have people who stop buying your
products if you target them because they
will get annoyed right they will say
like hey i'm buying this and they are
like
snagging me you know
that's annoying
i don't like it
and they will quit
so now with traditional machine learning
models you you are usually
uh
not able to model this very well
because of confining so if in your in
your data sets
you will have certain characteristics of
those people
and these characteristics uh
from
um
from correlational point of view
they might have different
um
they might have different proportions
than
than the groups that we just mentioned
so there might be some confounding right
so there might there might be some
uh there might be some characteristics
of those people that will affect both
uh
their behavior
given your even your campaign
and also their behavior
their behavior in general
so usually in these cases machine
learning models are not the most the
most efficient things that thing that
you can do uh when it comes to modeling
so so this is why this is why you're
using
you're using um
causal modeling for this
usually you just use certain methods for
causal inference for this you are not
going into discovery but you could go
into discovery if you have enough data
and so on and so on under certain let's
say circumstances that might be used
so this is one use case another use case
is in medicine
uh where you
when you want to understand what is the
impact of
um of a given drug or given therapy on
your patients
now there's there's a very nice drawing
um
i don't know by home i think judea pearl
has it in his book if i remember
i'm pretty sure i remember this
correctly let me
can i draw now
i cannot
maybe i can
i would cry
is it the example with the cancer
patients and drugs
or no it's slightly it's slightly
different so
so
yeah let's do it like this
okay this is some some data and here we
have exercise
and here we have cholesterol levels
okay
and maybe somehow surprisingly
we see that the correlation between
exercise and cholesterol levels is
positive
this is very counterintuitive right
if we build a machine learning model on
this
on this data
this is the effect that we will get
but there might be something else in
this data so there might be age as well
and maybe there are age groups and these
age groups are like this
so now
you can see that within
within each of those age groups
the relationship is have the has the
reverse sign
sign so this means that age is a
confounder because
people who are older
they in
they have more cholesterol in general
but they also exercise more
those who exercise more
among the oldest ones have much less
cholesterol than those who do not
so now
there are certain things regarding
proportions
even if you control 48 and it's in like
a regular machine learning model there
might be certain things regarding
proportions in your data
that will affect the estimates
of your machine learning model
and if you don't have this causal
information in the model
you are not able um
to to actually remediate this
does it make sense yes absolutely
alexander thank you great examples thank
you
thank you
[Music]
and your second question you also had a
second question so yes i don't want to
monopolize the discussion but i guess
it's a small one
um
the second question is the regarding the
algorithms that you saw um that you saw
us in the notebook
um if you can
comment a bit on the fitness metrics
that some of these algorithms were in
the score based methods for example
um the start of curiosity this is the
likelihood
fitness or
so so so so
for instance
most of those methods well they differ
but um
but the the let's say the classic ones
they are
mostly based on things like uh
bayesian information criterion bic
arguments
this type of stuff
but there are methods like golem is
actually a modification of another
method that is called no tears
which actually is not a very good method
for causal discovery but it contains
some
[Music]
some very
interesting ideas
and and these methods actually some of
those methods are actually using machine
learning or even like bayesian uh
generation
yeah yeah
thank you alexander great talk
thank you
do we have any more questions
alexander
um textual data often
contains model descriptions
and extracting model descriptions are
you aware of any work um
in that domain uh
combining uh
correlation data with
natural language model descriptions to
estimate or bias
uh model generation
very interesting uh let me just make
sure that i got your question right so
what you're asking um
what you're asking about is
that you might have a situation where
there is a causal relationship that is
described in natural language
and your question is
if there is
any research that could extract the
information about causal
about the causal model so build the
causal graph
based on natural language description is
that correct
yeah
yes that is
one element the other element is the
combination of natural language data
with uh you know sample data statistical
data correlation data
from the domain being described
so
i'm particularly interested in the
combination of the two
estimating a model
using the data
but in a way that is biased
by the causal descriptions in text or
vice versa
yeah so um
so so i'm not aware of any research
where people would try to actually build
a causal graph
based on
a a textual description
there is uh ongoing research when it
comes to causality and nlp
um
there are a couple of approaches there
uh people are trying to
excuse me i need to
my
so people are trying to
build a set of um
of assumptions
over natural language
and then
try to use causal models
to estimate
causal effects of text
so this is one line of research
so for instance it might be
maybe you are writing something
uh you're writing comments on social
media
and now we are trying to build a causal
model that will
that will explain
uh
some type of your decision based on your
comments in social media
right so we are trying to to understand
um what is the causal relationship
between
your natural language sentences
or some elements of those sentences and
some of some of your decisions so this
is one line of of research
um
[Music]
does this answer a question
yeah it um
so
in
my domain one of the
interesting
problems
is uh trying to extract causal
information from text
we have
for example uh metabolic pathway charts
which have graphical representations so
we have this convenient form for and
many of these metabolic pathway
databases which are
you know semantic knowledge bases
many of them also have attribution
information where it describes the
source in the literature
so it seems feasible to correlate the um
you know the metabolic pathways with the
text which describes them
and this is a case where a causal
structure in the real world is being
described by text
so
an interest one interesting challenge
there is to
uh look for other causal descriptions in
the literature
uh see if that uh mapping can be
automated say the
addition of new nodes to the uh
uh metabolic pathway chart
i think that's uh that's a very
interesting uh use case
uh what i can do i can share with you uh
and a review article about causality in
nlp
um
i think they do not cover
if i remember correctly they do not
cover anything that would be like
literally your use case
in in structural terms
uh but maybe you will be able to find
some inspiration there at least you at
least some starting points uh for for
further research
that would be great um in fact in
general if you have any surveys on this
or reviews on the subject that you can
that are fairly recent or fairly
comprehensive that you can recommend
um not merely on my use case but on
causal inference in general
i'm sure that many of the participants
would appreciate those links
great i have a couple of them let's
please feel free to
add me on linkedin
and i will share this with you and what
i will also do
um
tomorrow or maybe even i will try to do
it today i will add those papers to the
repository that we use today okay
so i'll add a couple of papers
uh
i will do a i will i'll just
push them into the repository
until let's say within half an hour from
um
from now okay very much appreciated i'm
sure that many of the participants will
make use of that thank you
great thank you anthony that's a very
that's a very uh very inspiring use case
and thank you for sharing this
okay um do we have any more comments or
questions
yeah so i i have also a question do you
have some kind of a further reading
except of this reviews but this is more
like a let's say scientific
literature review but like more like
courses or
books which are comprehensive about this
topic something like that thanks
are you interested particularly in
causal discovery
or in causal inference or
both
oh
mostly discovery but i think both also
is good
so so this is a little bit uh
so this is a little bit complicated
because i feel that there is no uh no
very good material that would be very
comprehensive and also uh and also
practical i would say
uh that said
there are a couple of books on this
so
one of them
is this
you know what you can just let me see if
you can see my
you can see this okay
oh no we won't see this because it's
blurred so it's elements of causal
inference let me type it in the chat
[Music]
by pictures and
colleagues uh but actually i would not
start with this if if you want to start
with something
with like a very good review that would
be introduction
connection oh let me check it
i don't remember the title but i have it
somewhere here
[Music]
it's called causal inference in
statistics and primer
um causal inference in
statistics
a
primer and this is by julia
judea pearl
and colleagues
and if you want like an introduction
introduction
uh
a great book is a book of why a book of
why by pearl
and then if you want to go
actually
actually i'll give you one more
[Music]
causality
the mixtape i think that's the title
it's by by coming
coming cunning i'm
gone
yeah this is more like econometrics
points of view
but uh it's also very interesting so i
think these four books should give you
like a good
basics
um and actually
uh
well you'll be you'll be the first
people who
hear this in public but i'm actually
working on a book uh on causality which
will be causal inference and discovery
in python
so it will have
a comprehensive theoretical overview but
it will be also very practical and based
on python and written from more from
a machine learning point of view
because there is there is also a good
literature in um
in this
in this area coming from econometrics uh
research
uh but it's a slightly different point
of view than a machine learning point of
view i'd say
does it answer your question
yeah it's perfect i'm waiting for your
book then
thank you
thank you
one more book that i thought about is
what's its name
i need to check i'm sorry
i don't remember
i don't remember the title
but i have it here as well so
it shouldn't take long
for me to find it
yeah okay
it's called what if
so let me
let me add it here uh most of those
books if not all of them can either be
read online for free
or you can even download a a copy for
free
from from from the offers web page i
mean not from some
illegal source so most of them are
available for free in some form
if you if you want
great
just i'm sorry just a classification you
mean
what if book by randall monroe from this
x
k c d comic
no no no it's what if by
yeah i was confused
it's it's uh it's what if is by
hernan and robbins
okay thank you
yes
so these are the offers in the chat
okay great
do we have any more questions maybe the
last question or last remark if anybody
feels like
thank you
okay so then i think we are we are done
alexandros did you want to say something
i would like to thank you so much for
this fantastic tour de force i really
enjoyed it
although i was not
i was so busy this day so i was not so
proactive so
i will come back with some questions
actually and
do you have you ever talked to
philosophers about causality it might
sound weird but since you are interested
in conceptual things have you ever had
discussions with philosophers of science
on causality
you know a part of my background is in
philosophy of language so yes i did
great yeah because i have a very cool
contact i really enjoyed oh
that's great i'm happy to expand if you
have people in your mind so let's link
to linkedin and let's let's talk about
it i'm very happy to discuss it sure
great
um
yeah so let's wrap it up then and
give a round of applause to alexander
yeah reactions reactions reactions
thank you
and see you
yeah in two months guys thank you for
joining
thank you so much for joining
thank you so much so as i said i will
push the papers into the repository
within 30 minutes from
from now
great that was that was a great pleasure
to